alright hey see Mike welcome to the
corridor podcast welcome change the
studio looks totally different yeah
right yeah he has a bunch of really
unique houses all over his very boxy we
have a place in the studio called memory
lane apparently except it's we reversed
all the letters it was a weird printing
mistake showing backwards for you guys
yes so I spent two minutes bringing it
in the editor in reversing it so I can
bring it in first I thought it was
Russian yeah
so let me see Mike how you been oh man I
I've been super relaxed and I've been
doubling down on judges and Dragons and
finding myself that's I think the
biggest thing it's been intense
yeah I mean you did you did something
that's very challenging to do which is
to make the leap from stability to chaos
with the intent of pursuing personal
desires and fulfillment and I'm hoping
that you'll you'll share a little bit of
your experiences with us and like you
know what brought you that point and
like what you've learned about yourself
in terms of in from doing that and you
know all the things that come with it so
yeah I mean Cooper to everyone listening
this podcast I'm sure they know who you
are but if they don't I mean I should
let you introduce yourself so I'm
Carmichael I used to be the t-shirt guy
who packed the t-shirts for stress level
zero in corridor digital and then I had
to bring the shirts to the mailbox and
then one day I was allowed to edit some
behind the scenes stuff and then I
became a showrunner of a vlog called
corridor crew and then Nick hopped on
and we got married and we had a raise a
child with uncle Nico and Sam it's
grandpa Nico actually
Uncle Jake yeah and then about a year
ago this time you you departed ways with
corridor and start pursuing your own
endeavors primarily the dungeons and
dungeons and dragons channel fables a
refuge right yeah it's its fables now
originally I was going to just be fables
but I was like oh we should just mark it
it off the main show that we're trying
to make and then once I can start
putting more stuff on there I'll take
off refuge yeah it's I it's a it's a
mixed bag on how the decision got made
on my part and then when I discovered
D&D I got reading Kinect I got
reconnected with my childhood something
that a lot of adults seek and my heart
just like started to glow and warm up it
was like the exact feeling whenever my
dad walked me through the gates of the
Renaissance Fair and I was nice as an
adult I never had that feeling until I
started playing D&D
and I was like this is important and I
can't let this go and then that brought
up the the reminder of what I've been
pursuing since I don't know middle
school so like seventh grade and what
I've let go to pursue it which is
filmmaking and then that cut there was a
conflict of interest in me like all I
did was focus on filmmaking nothing else
I would skip lunches at school I would
stay late get in there early and just
focus on filmmaking nothing else
I actually abandoned a lot of
friendships and social connections just
to stay on the path of filmmaking this
is like whatever
how do I make movies how do I do that
well and how how can I know how to do it
like all that knowledge I just want it
and I landed the [ __ ] dream job
and I got a corridor and I was like it
was the dream job and when you started
it wasn't the dream job because it
wasn't for the guys that I admire and I
was like I mean that's the next step
like learnt like when I was at film
school when I got to LA in 2012 two
things were always in my mind
one podcasts are gonna replace radio -
it doesn't make sense what teachers are
teaching me because it's like during the
day I'm learning studio filmmaking and
at night I'm watching corridor digital
and Freddy W and then the school would
say no what they're doing is bad and
wrong and then I was like I disagree I'm
saying that or just kind of like there
was a couple teachers who were like
there as part-time between like
directing gigs or producing gigs that
they're like yeah I can't wait to see
what these people get to do in the long
run but then the majority of them who
were like full-time teachers at a film
school we're like no they're doing it
wrong yeah of course there's no film in
their camera you know the developing lab
budget for that they like the organic
nature of films was the video texture
today I remember we out of pocket
students had to pay for our own film
because they wanted like the first three
things we shoot were on actual film yeah
I was like okay I'll do like the first
one and the second one the second one I
just shot on whatever leftover film I
had but the third one is like I don't
have this money but I knew someone with
the
SLR I was like can I just shoot on the
pier solar no that's not film but mmm
then I started pointing I showed them
like the Philip Bloom footage from the
ranch and stuff I'm like it kind of
looks like film to me yeah
but then yeah I got to work with you
guys after working at a cloud imperium I
think I think it was Jake who called me
up and it's like hey we got a gig for a
week to do Mordor and there's no pay but
we can make sure you're fed and you got
a place to sleep I turn to my boss like
hey I'm gonna be gone for a week and
that began the road of me being fired
and yeah so you I mean you know you went
from you know being a guy helping out
around the studio kind of like helping
Jake take care of some work to you know
obviously shore running the entire court
or Kreuger channel and you know at least
like when my dad had talked me about
like getting a job and stuff like that
he was like you know when you put
yourself in a position where people
start coming to you to get something
done you soon find yourself in a
position of leadership where people are
coming to you to get stuff done so just
be that person and give it time and in
time you know you'll find yourself in
those positions that you want to be in
and you know I feel like that's it's
kind of what you ended up just doing
where you're like all right I'm just
gonna start doing work and then I get
the opportunities I'm going to do them
and keep cranking on them but what was
was that evolution like for you like
from your point of view how did you get
from a guy packing t-shirts to a guy
who's you know inventing formats and
making videos that millions people are
watching one who's can't it has to be
said like without Nick's help the
channel wouldn't have become what it is
I have to also preference that back like
a big part of when I left is like
working on myself and then looking at my
state of mind through that process - and
there was a lot of like too much pride
like almost like I I deserved because I
knew I put so much energy and knowing so
much about filmmaking
whenever I wasn't doing filmmaking I
felt like I deserved to do filmmaking
why am I doing this but then often I got
put in my place whenever like you guys
try to put me in the hot seat and I
froze and it's just like and it's just I
wasn't humble enough back then but then
I was also hungry enough to constantly
like try to achieve a new thing I
remember I presented the idea to both
you and Sam the idea of like hey the Sam
and Nico channel should have like an
opening logo and I really liked the idea
of the t-shirt hold down the chest and I
was like you should be animated some way
as I could begin animator do that and
Nico you so straight up said no we can't
afford that I just stood there for like
a half a second I was like okay I went
to my computer and for the next six days
I learned how to do it and that's what
sucked was it was a final JPEG I'm just
gonna get a higher res picture of the
shirt and work from that yeah I remember
thoughts of just like
because when I started shooting my my
idea was I should make the better
version of what you guys are already
doing with BTS which is covering the
action getting what you guys have to say
on set and then essentially recapping
some ideas in an interview and then try
to make those all look sorry we're
basically doing our version of DVD and
then it was just like take the neck like
okay how does this get better how does
this get better and it was getting
really good and then it took its biggest
leap when Nikko you you were like let's
do a vlog Jake's idea Jake's idea for
the longest time but then one day let's
do it the Sony camera was never turned
off I'm trying to remember cuz Ren
complimented me on always doing the whip
zooms and I was my thought back then was
like you know it's always funny when you
crash zoom in the editing into
somebody's face I should just do it in
camera and save myself some time so
think that like the thing that like I
think really like anybody who's at
corridor that's been bitten with us for
a while and like you know they fit in
really well
and exhale excel at what they're doing I
think they all share a common trait and
that they are always thinking about you
know outside of just way students work
there's lots of work there's regular
work that has happened but every but
there everybody's always thinking about
like
how can I improve what can I do that's
new what can I do next what can I invent
what's something that no one's thought
of yet
that I can explore and try they think
you know anyone that's with us that's
you know that's really making a mark for
themselves has that process going on
yeah on top of just the regular like
being a decent editor being good at time
management being you know you know a
hard worker all those things are
obviously a mess are necessary but then
you know bring to the table that like
hey I have an idea for this format let's
try this or hey you know I was thinking
you know we could do this better I read
these you know comments here and they
said you know what about the trying like
this and it got me thinking about this
and like that's something comical that
you like you it was really a big part of
your process like you were always
thinking about trying new things I mean
you know like for example like you know
you and Nick when you guys put together
like the first VFX react idea you know
that was just say like hey the sonic
trailer came out you guys VFX artists
why don't you talk about why people
don't like it and why it looks weird and
you know that was just an example of you
know of many because like we didn't have
an established format outside of just
like we need to do a video two or three
times a week like there wasn't like a
standard format that each video followed
so there's always being reinvented no
like I guess this is a question both to
Nick and Carmichael is this something
that like you guys think it's just
inherent in who you are or it's just
something that you had to train yourself
to do over time oh well I can't answer
for Carmichael I think it's more
inherent in you Carmichael than me at
that time I was so used to trying to
well just like I was getting used to the
groove like trying to like work in your
workflow and then Carmichael would
always like you know one day would pass
and then you'd be like I have a bright
idea
let's change everything but I mean that
was for the beginning and then
eventually it just found a fluid you
know evolution and there's no there's no
year of those vlogs that are the same
right because he's constantly changing
and then eventually we yet we found that
react format and it was like okay here's
a first format that actually sticks yeah
even that was an accident like finding
that format wasn't something we were
trying it wasn't like intentionally like
hey react videos do really well let's
just do that it's because we're all
going away to Texas when we're thinking
about moving and we needed something
quick to shoot and didn't take you know
like a week of pre pro so we could just
draw on the knowledge that you guys had
and that we all had and you know turn
that into something and yeah the sonic
trailer just happened to be it
definitely the biggest shift for the
channel right there yeah it was a huge
shift I still I can't see his name but
someone did tell me when the sonic
trailer dropped like that was a false
trailer they had the final design for
Sonic already done and that was just
another design for marketing so that way
so they could say oh yeah we listen to
the fans because if it's true it's I
remember the the sonic react video Abby
and I approached it the same way I
generally approach all videos when I'm
in the editing seat is if I'm passively
watching this how am i experiencing it
from the moment I click to whenever I
leave and that's often why I would stay
like hours late or work over the
weekends it's like I'm not feeling it
like whatever this video is like in if I
just jump in what what's my experience
on the roller coaster you know mm-hmm
and that's how I approached the editing
of that react video and then it was like
we dissected the hell out of it it was
like what
order were things that happen bad clip
and in the marketing clip and we didn't
even have those concepts yeah it was
like oh it kind of worked okay let's do
that exactly the same yeah and then boom
and then I was like alright yeah so you
know so see Mike you know obviously you
the decision to lead corridor was
something that you had decided upon
months and months and months before it
happened no it wasn't a surprise or
anything like that
once it you know came time for you to
head out and you made the you made the
jump from you know obviously being at
corridor and working with a group of
people and you know having other people
around you to doing your own thing and
at least for me something like that
could be really scary and be really
challenging tell me a little bit about
that like what has been how did you feel
when that happened had there been like
whatever your moments of victory been
whatever your challenge has been as
you've made the transition okay I mean
what first off leading up to me like
talking to you guys about me leaving it
was it was that moment like kicking in
of like realizing I spent so much time
focusing on my craft which is not
inherently a bad thing but I put it
before everything else in my life like
everything else and at a certain point
it started getting to me like I don't
have anything else so I am endlessly now
making content for contents sake I'm
telling stories just non-stop
and it's like before I would go to sleep
I would talk about corridor content
the moment I wake up within five minutes
my brain is thinking of the next
corridor content that I'm working on and
I couldn't just get out of it and that
started building up D&D kicked in and I
reconnected to something and that led to
like I have to tell these guys like I
need to completely walk away to put time
into me whatever way that's possible I
have to figure it out and like if I do a
hard fail on this it's like I I always
knew that our relationship was good
enough that I can always come back to
you guys and say I couldn't I couldn't
figure this out and knowing that like
you guys had that love and that
friendship for me did make it easier but
not any less scary yeah yeah like I even
had to talk to my dad because he was
like you got the best job what do you
why are you leaving like oh I kind of
need to figure stuff out for myself and
it might mean like making my own thing
even if it fails he's like I don't know
like thanks dad I mean there is
something to be said for that from the
outside perspective what we do looks
like the best job and you have to
sometimes it's like you have to remind
people like this is pretty consuming
stuff like you have to put a lot into it
not just riding one wheels and goofing
around and reacting to videos all day
you know yeah there's a whole the VFX
artists side of VFX artists react like
you still have to go out there and learn
how to do the effects years and years of
work and you also gotta like put the
work into learning the effects not the
act of practicing it like I need to know
when Ren goes on a rant
I need to be able to there to sit there
and keep up so that way I can question
him on something that he just raced on
by because he just knows the terminology
in the like the back of his hand better
than the back of his hand
yeah so movies like sorry keep going
yeah so once once I left I was like okay
I have two months of rent I need to
either one find consistent work with
another creator that I genuinely want to
put some energy in learn to work with a
kind of like a creative friend and like
that build the DND thing on the side and
put the energy in me or just which is
the worst option is hustle hustle hustle
gig after gig after gig after gig I was
able to get a job at Indy mogul and I
was brought I was like oh yeah so for
your experience that corridor would love
you to help with the direction of
rebirthing Indy mogul I was like that's
awesome I love Indy mogul let's do it
and six months later I'm late on every
delivery because all they want is an
editor 9:00 to 5:00 yeah
but every meeting I have like equipment
upgrade ideas setup up great ideas new
styled branding ideas and they're like
this isn't what we brought you on for I
was like I thought that was yeah and
it's like I I can't sit in the back
office for 9:00 to 5:00 and not do
anything but look at a computer screen
with no access to sunlight and there was
always the ability to get up and record
and shoot and the other guys were in
charge of doing that
so I parted ways and I was like all
right I'm down to one month savings of
rent okay this is Thanksgiving the lot
last Thanksgiving
she made it from May to November mm-hmm
and fables has launched write fables has
already launched we were releasing an
episode once a month because I was
trying to go what if I release a full
D&D episode just once at a time like
what's the consistency was the thought
process what's the feeling behind it
then eventually we went to what we're
doing now but I'm at the Thanksgiving I
have to fly to Sacramento to be with
Ali's family so I was like all right
can't afford that so Ali's family family
pays for it and now I'm feeling like
less of a provider less more of a
failure because it's like I'm not
something's not working and I can't see
it on top of that premiere has been
glitching out all my videos so it was
just like November was the month of
learning how to breathe hmm December I
had probably my worst panic attack
because there was zero in my bank
account Wow was that moment just like
holy [ __ ] this is real now like I really
made the jump yeah and I was like I lit
like the moment I woke up to the moment
I went to sleep my thought was I'm
losing this this apartment I'm I'm not
going to be able to protect Alicia I'm
not going to be able to protect the cats
and at this point my cats
or my babies and I just started seeing
myself as a failure and I I also at the
same time was trying to not see myself
as a failure because I know if I said
that narrative too much I wouldn't be
able to get out of that narrative and so
it's like I wake up fables fables like
how can I improve it how can I make it
better how do I minimize the workflow
how do I minimize the equipment how do I
increase resolution how do I increase
quality and it was small steps patreon
was like sitting there able to help me
pay rent but I was like this is money
that people donated to me to put towards
this content so it was like only on the
final hour will I ever make the decision
to use their money to keep a roof over
my head I was trying to be that noble
and it came it came down to the the last
minute and I got an email it December I
was able to pay rent with help of family
and I paid them back but January comes
along I'm still freaking out because
zero is still there but I gained email
from Richard Ryan from black rifle
coffee he's like I've only met Richard
Ryan that one time we did the slow-mo
video with rent oh yeah hey are you
still doing are you doing freelance yet
I remember you talking about you guys
you were leaving I was like yeah I'm
still doing freelance I have no clients
he's like call get you hooked up with
Logan we have a project we basically
want to do corridor crew meets Peter
McKinnon who's the we
Richard Richard Richard for black rifle
oh and so Logan
hit me up we talked he basically wants
to make up behind the scenes show with
the mindset of corridor crew like behind
the company the work that we put into
the company what is that and I was like
yeah let's do that
and he's like cool on Friday can you fly
out to Las Vegas for shot show mmm my
first question was what the [ __ ] is shot
show it's basically NAB but with guns
instead of okay hold on hold on my
camera it just popped up 10% plug in see
Mike he's like can you fly out there I
was like yeah I totally can he's like
cool so we keeps talking about what
we're gonna do there and all the
traveling that's gonna have to happen
while we're there and only okay okay I'm
in might and I'm writing down how much
everything's going to cost and and like
I have I have one camera I have one lens
I have a friend's microphone mmm and I
have one SD card and I took Alicia's
laptop and he goes all right cool so
we'll cover the flights and all your
transportation all your food I'll see
you on Friday and I'll email you all the
addresses
and I just worked my ass off that week I
was like if these guys can be a
consistent client I'm going to make that
a thing on top of that black rifle
coffee is a veteran company supports
veterans I come from a family of
veterans I'm one of the first boys to
not join the military
well my son's and my dad loves black
rifle coffee too Oh Evan Evan the owner
of black rifle and I make a joke about
how when I went vegan my dad lost his
pride of being my father and then when I
started working black rifle he got I got
it back amazing I gotta be honest when I
heard that you were working with them I
was like whoa there's a disconnect like
your name is like a very like you know
more left-sided I mean you're like the
first person and I think the only in the
studio to go vegan right or is Griffin
Griffin's vegetarian but you were though
he's vegetarian definitely like cook it
yeah as a lifestyle so I was just like
wow okay how's that gonna work out Oh
their faces were amazed reaction like
what like what an interesting first
initiation to be like thrown into shot
show like biggest gun culture from LA
just like it was what was weird was
being around the guys growing up in a
town of 200 people in Minnesota and
almost every weekend being around
military people because of my dad going
to base to base it almost felt like home
just hanging out with the guys
it was so surreal when I remember we sat
in to record the behind the scenes of
them recording one of their podcast
episodes in the hotel evan buys me a
like a green smoothie drink
he gets one we go up the elevator we're
talking we're talking and we sit down
and he makes a crack about vegans
because he's drinking a shitty green
drink and I go I know I'm one of them
okay
he all he does is he looks up Matt best
in the back goes wait
you're a [ __ ] vegan like yeah [ __ ]
a what was funny is like ten minutes
later
Matt best was trying to offer me a
full-time job hmm because according to
him like the last BTS guy wouldn't do
the things I would do to get the shot
like I we were shooting at a gun range
and I was asking the guys who worked
there can you pull out the gun so I can
get this b-roll shot at this Bureau shot
hey can you toss the bullets over here
so I can get the shot and he was just
straight-up impressed that I was putting
the initiative and the work to get a
good product hmm like even if I don't
use that footage I'm putting that work
in yeah I mean that goes miles you're
scrubbing those floors man sweeping
those floors open those floors yeah and
working with Logan it's a similar
relationship as like working with one of
you guys he has a creative mindset
a creative mindset too so we'll often
just do the work all day long and then
the evening just banter about the
direction of the video direction of the
next video like what's the through line
to the next story what
the overall thing we're trying to do
what's interesting about it pretty much
every night in Guatemala him and I were
drinking wine doing that so you went to
Guatemala with those guys how long so I
went home Logan wanted me to come back
the next week and we would just go to
Florida for NASCAR I couldn't make it I
so I had to take that one specific week
off but I could have worked one week the
next week and then the next week all
free it's a really casual little coffee
car one yeah oh wow yeah and then the
following week I had to fly it down to
Texas and shoot there for a week behind
the scenes and then doing a video that's
in post so I'm not gonna talk about it
cuz I haven't talked to anything about
it man like I get on the airplane at
5:00 a.m. I didn't I pretty much didn't
sleep that night
cuz I was just still nervous I have two
months of rent in my account right now
no other money to anything else I was
like keep a roof keep a roof nothing
else I get to Texas and then gained a
car the sun's now shining and get show
up at their office I have to pull up the
camera and start shooting and I shoot
for the next eight hours and then I go
to the ranch and I sleep at the ranch
and that's the first time I could sleep
in 48 hours he cuddled up with the
taxidermy animals we walk in that room
was like blows my mind
please like cool though but like last
year you're like yeah we're gonna part
ways I'm gonna do my own thing for a bit
and then suddenly it's like intersecting
no yeah yeah we hung out at the ranch
for the bit too we did all that it's
like we surprisingly shared very similar
experience probably yeah Evan was Evan
is the best joke sir like it's funny is
like he'll call from call for me to do
something he'll be like hey vegan and
Logan be like it's Carmichael and it's
Nevin plays it so straight that he's
like what is the word Carmichael and the
moment I got to shoot at the ranch I was
like okay I'm I have my foot in the door
with them as a client I'm gonna keep
working my ass off to keep them as a
client because they're able to afford a
rate that keeps me alive and I also at
this moment so it's before April March
was Guatemala so it's February at this
moment working with them going to Texas
and everything I realize the most
important thing that working with these
guys right now is going to be for my
mental health if I'm a vegan and I'm
extremely left on a lot of things and I
live in Los Angeles
I have an echo chamber around me yeah
and if I can throw myself at an
environment that is often extremely
opposite of my my perspective I will be
able to question my morals and ethics
and chip away at them until they are the
most essential to my belief
and I can know myself the best not
everyone would do that not everyone's
like willing to walk into you know what
could be a cauldron of opposite views of
their own and just you know let it burn
them but I mean it seems like it's all
in good fun and you've I mean have there
been any views that since leaving that
the bubble right of LA has working with
those guys with other perspectives
changed any of your perspectives I think
when switching to veganism a big thing
is like as you guys know I'm an all in
kind of person yes it's a verb now
Carmichael Lee so going vegan is like
saying no to everything else and like
absorb and learn what is this and then
also what is this to me and then hanging
around those guys and they often raise
questions that I couldn't answer and so
I got to sit on those questions that no
one else around me would ask that
question and it reminds me that I'm a
vegan who loves guns no these are my
trees get the [ __ ] away
don't touch my tomatoes it's
understanding like there is the veganism
is not something that's perfect for
every individual person and you can't
admit that when you start going down
that road because you have to if you're
trying to go down something what you
think is the better thing for you you
kind of have to follow it with faith and
then once you start getting a little bit
of a comfort bubble that's where you're
like okay
I've gone pretty far what about is this
what what can I poke holes in that I can
question and often especially in
Guatemala I would bring up things that
Evan would ask he would talk about wool
which is not an animal's skin it's you
know their hair and I mentioned well it
depends on where you get it like I have
to do the thought process of like only
certain farms take care of their animals
better than others and you need to
support those farmers and if it comes
from a Murray Oh sheep for example you
don't want the mewling and a Murray Oh
sheep for example is a domesticated
sheep so it just keeps growing it's it's
wool not like a wild sheep that sheds
and if and if a person doesn't cut give
them a haircut they can die they heat up
they sweat they suffocate and their
sweat their sweat actually attracts a
specific type of fly that's native in
Australia that kills them and so to
prevent sheep from dying from that fly
you have to mule them which is you
lassoed them up and cut the skin off the
back of their hind legs and it's like
and it's hard because in the vegan
community is like no all wool is bad I
was like okay so we need to prevent the
wool being worn by people yeah okay why
not I actually asked the question why
not eradicate sheep hmm you you would
stop cruelty by taking them out well
that's that's not ethical okay so what
is the most ethical thing is to support
farmers who are doing it more ethically
than others
who take care and love their animals
because their domesticated animals they
rely on us and I have a bunch of other
examples like that that Evan and I had
long conversations about that he never
knew about mmhmm yeah that's really
interesting stuff in my experience the
black graph will coffee guys I mean
outside of this like boundless derive
that like leaves me exhausted and I
thought I had some decent Drive like
Jake put pretty well it's like you if
you approach them with the caricature of
like you know the Texas like guy that
loves his guns and his meat like you'll
you'll you'll have it you'll apply
stereotypes of them that aren't true
because you also end up I mean that upon
meeting the guys you'll find that they
are some of the most like tolerant and
accepting guys you know yeah and they
just don't like they don't make a point
of trying to censor themselves but in
the set that throws you off at first but
then you realize that they're they don't
really have any the sensor because
there's nothing in them that's like you
know awkwardly judgmental or harsh or
cruel because they're not this kind of
people yeah so they're really
fascinating guys and you know the really
cool guys see that you know I've met
that yeah I'm friends with I be
obviously a bunch of them as well yeah
so it's a really good crew and I'm I'm
happy that they have the success they
have and that they've found the niche
and the the community that they have
because they seem like they've attracted
a bunch of other guys who are having the
same mindset together to you know
execute on this vision that they have um
which is great so you know you were
saying though so you went to Guatemala
you know you did the shot show to Vegas
are you still working with them
part-time just like a freelance client
so quick shot show imagine going to NAB
and there are you know everyone's always
filming everything because you know
everyone's got to put out their nab
video right of course there's no such
thing at cha cha nobody's filming
there was two other freelance
videographers and I know that there were
only two because I could never find one
and those two found me and go are you
Carmichael oh wow and it as Logan and
Evan put it it's like yeah YouTube and
online video platforms are anti right
they're anti-gun least it leads to
violence and so black rifle can sit like
just on the the line because they're not
a gun company they're a coffee company
and that was an insane experience
because so many people were
uncomfortable of a cameraman near them
and then you also have people who didn't
understand like Oh someone's taking a
picture or video is recording whereas
any Beast
you'd have playing people who kind of
kind of stop and just wait for a second
yeah that kind of pulls you out of LA -
it's like these are normal people you
they're not gearheads they're not camera
people they're not Hollywood yeah just
gun salesman with an honest product what
what okay so I do not want this was this
is an opening in my mind as a video
creator what I
I did not expect do we all remember
street meat guy oh yeah yeah wait was
hitch gosh I don't know he has that shot
show he was not a rifle coffee's got
their own street meat guy oh really yes
and it dawned on me I don't know why did
Donna me before it's like every tribe
every community online has the hardest
of hardcore fans that
that's all they want to break and it
humbled me even more being at a vegan at
shot show mm-hmm yeah I imagine I
mention those guys have a lot of fans at
shot show oh yeah yeah crazy I mean
they're the biggest like celebrities
when it comes to that space there's a
the only other people are like what like
what's it the the guy from demolition
ranch yeah he's like the closest other
person in that space yeah I think I shot
a terabyte of footage in that week Wow
all HD at 120 frames per second yeah no
you just you said the high frame rate
because when you're at shot show you
never know when a guns gonna go yes you
want to make sure it's in slow motion we
all know we all remember why I was like
hey we should switch to 60 frames per
second yeah in case you ever wanted to
do slow motion yeah so my Sony camera
can record audio at HD 120 frames per
second okay so I just shoot in HD 120
Wow and it's a hundred megabits per
second different sequence I just edit at
30 frames per second okay that's pretty
cool man technology yeah and then
Guatemala I shot almost two terabytes I
had to use my one terabyte SD card as a
half of a backup so I would never delete
footage off of it like what was what
were you covering while you were there
so the first couple days was footage
just be rolling footage so we went to
different coffee farms okay learning the
process from coffee getting from the
field to the kind of stuff Wow
it's also note the first time I've been
in a third-world country as an adult
what was that like a minute they're so
poor the pickers are so poor that they
have to be vegan hmm that's how it was
worded to me yeah they're lucky if they
get five thousand a year in u.s. Wow Wow
no don't shake your boots and is this
you know are these farmers that you're
describing is that where a lot of the
coffee that we drink comes from like is
this like the coffee capital of world or
something or is it a more niche area
Guatemala
I believe always has been exporting and
they're just now getting into the system
of like trying to regain their coffee
culture because they would always leave
the shitty coffee for themselves and
sell the good stuff and now they're
trying to keep some of the good stuff to
be part of that culture yet I think the
I have the time line open I think our
Shepherd Freddy he said more than 60% of
the coffee is what you guys end up
getting in your cup and the process is
nuts like there are major companies in
the industry that buy the leftover stuff
in bulk so they can sell big containers
of coffee for high profit but low cost
they're just there the coffee that they
were going to throw out mm-hmm and then
learning about that whole side of the
industry too crazy and then learning the
learning cupping blew my mind what's
coming so you guys know what
wine-tasting is yeah so cupping is that
for coffee
they had a cup over I think it was
almost like a tea different tastes of
coffee in a single day okay wait how do
you hadn't even distinguish that that
flavor profile like after after 20 cups
of coffee when it just all turn into
yeah you have to meet
Edwin who has a 24 karat gold tasting
spoon for coffee he's certified as like
a coffee taster he's like he's the main
guy blacc rifle that's Evan Edwin a sir
that's a buddy yeah he works yeah I
think I may have met him before because
they have a crazy laboratory in the
background where they have a sleeper
chill dude yeah they uh like I remember
when we were filming our commercial last
year I went back there I was like hey is
there like just like um like a basic
coffee carafe kind of a coffee maker a
mr. coffee kind of thing and it's like
oh yeah yeah we keep a couple in the
back and it's like oh yeah well and then
he explains also further it's like yeah
we try and also always get the worst
coffee makers you can possibly buy like
the mr. coffee drip coffee ones because
we want to know how like the average
person is gonna consume this coffee and
want to see what its gonna be like when
you just make it poorly so to speak when
you're not doing the power over method
and all that stuff mm-hmm
yeah that's the same principle with us
not mixing in our color grading or
looking at the thumbnail very small how
does the audio sound like through yeah
phone speaker you got to view it through
the lens of your your consumer you know
yeah wild so so you're saying like
people there would you say on average
people are vegan like or on vegan
they're just like foods no no like
Pickers pickers and okay Pickers are
lucky to afford meat like when you go to
skid row like imagine being stuck in
skid row and a full-time job yeah and
your kids have to work with you that's
all families there's whole family it's
like one of the farms we had to take a
helicopter for 45 minutes just to get to
one of these farms and they support I
think it was
300 families and then on picking season
they have up to like 6000 employees and
then like if you if you're not going up
the mountain to handpick all the
cherries put it in a bag and carry it
down the mountain you have to do that
about like five times each bags 150
pounds cherries are young coffee no so
coffee beans are inside a cherry right
right it's like the red berry looking
thing right yeah okay and if you're not
doing that you can go cut grass with a
short machete cuz you're not going they
don't have lawnmowers so you just go is
the coffee industry it seems like that's
major industry is it regulated do you
know like are there laws in place to
protect people or is it just kind of
Wild West British colonialism
you know plantation so it's both there's
a quote in the video I don't want to say
that quote because it's such a good
quote they have to watch the video you
have to watch the video and it's still
being worked on there there's
regulations to an extent because
Guatemala terrain is full of mountains
where the coffee's are grown so you
can't have like in Brazil
the lands are more flat so you get a
machinery work there you can't do that
you need people interesting who can do
this labor for low cost because if you
wanted if if everyone in the US was
willing to pay like one to two dollars
more for their coffee you could
guarantee guarantee clean water for
Pickers that's it just one to two more
one to two more dollars per bag if this
is going off my memory we're talking to
Evan
the the math is based on because in this
it was like in the 70s a cup of coffee
was like 50 Cent's right so to consider
that with Fairtrade like what you would
want to pay people and inflation
Americans should be minimum buying like
$30.00 bags of coffee interesting to
provide like back to the farms and a big
concern when when we're in a room was
like why is the cost of coffee not
skyrocketing right now like coffee is in
the highest demand and it's like it
costs more to buy coffee right now but
it's cost less to make it and yet
farmers are still not getting enough so
that that whole week was an experience
beyond I've ever had as an adult I can
for many factors but that's that's
insane man were you how was like kind of
zoning and more on personal like
struggle I guess how was traveling there
as someone with a dietary restriction
cuz dude I mean I went to Spain last
year with my girlfriend who she's not
vegan
she just doesn't eat like meat meat and
that was hard traveling so how was being
a vegan in you know South America a
third-world country
well it
I totally say while I was there it's
like it's both easy and hard because
it's hard because it's I can just quit I
can just cheat there's so much like I
could just do it and be easier because
I'm putting so much mental energy in
shooting and so much work put into that
while traveling through Guatemala like I
would rather not put the energy into my
diet I would rather just eat something
right now what if you just like slipped
a little bit of carnitas and you know
would you'd probably suffer for that
right like you know that make you
physically sick though I'd get I get a
tummy ache which would then mess with my
performance but it's it's all so easy
because I can just ask the waiter what
do you have this vegetarian and then can
we just remove a few things they were
pretty accommodating oh yeah I I ate a
whole pizza because I found out their
crust wasn't made with egg I was like
I'll take it and then someone there was
like you know being a vegan you don't
eat a lot of meat but you sure do eat a
[ __ ] ton of food yeah well they were
surprised by the amount that you were
eating yeah I would in a single sitting
out eat two to three full meals gotcha
cuz for life or for ex-soldiers you know
I think that they'd also be meat when
meat in the idea of like density of
calories and protein and everything fats
like it's a superfood like humans found
a superfood we cooked it and we progress
past other animals plants you just got
to get a large combination of variety
and do that superfood on your own
thank you yeah and then there was the
hot tub
Oh indie game this is the D&D game okay
okay what's the hot tub story so we're
all sitting in a hot tub in Guatemala on
the edge of a volcanic lake okay
the this sense starting to work with
Logan Logan quit can't understand D&D
okay
and eventually evan is in on this and
he's like what is this I don't
understand this and at to the point
where he's asking every owner of black
rifle like do you know what dandy is -
have you ever played what is this what
is this we're all in the hot tub and it
comes down to can you just show us what
the India's okay I'm sitting with Evan
Logan the director of coffee
Edwin and Marty who's their journalist
we're all just sitting in a hot tub in
Guatemala and then it starts to rain so
we put the umbrella up and we're sitting
in the hot tub while raining and we're
playing D&D that sounds pretty freaking
and no dice I didn't think about using
[Laughter]
we played D&D
and they got out they it took them two
hours to get out of the tavern and to a
village why two hours just drinking oh
yeah they were also drinking like 10 12
15 beers each in game it's like more
like 40 or so so by the end of the game
Evan was so fascinated that he's like
put together a game for us so we can
shoot something
and I was like all right black rifle
coffee does D&D oppress hilarious
when can we look forward to that no 90
times 50 just just I already did one
that was like a sealed like Black Hawk
Down style one you could just that would
be perfect for them
you're behind enemy lines you gotta
extract these hostages from like a
tavern and there's orcs everywhere yeah
far off what I have yeah
I'm leaning a little bit more to Seven
Samurai yeah so to seem like I gotta ask
around the topic of D&D so you know your
channel fables
we didn't trying different things and
exploring it what I can get it now where
you gonna go with it what's what's your
current plans with it I want the current
show that's on there fables of refuge
with where Jarrett DMS I want that to be
a live show multicam live I get to sit
and play I get to be a player and what
I'm shooting tomorrow with Alicia is a
one-on-one where I DM and my idea for
that is to do a very spicy heavy edit
and well designed and something very
like cinematic I'm gonna play with that
though the whole idea of the channel is
to be a canvas for me to play D&D but
also for me to tinker with filmmaking at
the same time that is its primary
purpose in my eyes it's like okay so you
can't just play D&D you have to lean
more to like hey guys we're doing a
video okay so let's not do these things
okay so that changes playing Dungeons &
Dragons how does that feel as a creator
how does that feel as a player
how does it feel as the audience often
I'll sit there and look at it and go
that's a little that's not working for
me that's little cringy but then the
I'll get a comment of someone saying I
love it
this is great hmm I was like I made okay
this made someone's day better yeah so
I'm on a path it amounted path of making
something that people like and it's
something that connects me to my
childhood of fantasy and medieval mm-hmm
and then I also have to be realistic
it's like that channel doesn't make the
numbers to be a paying job mm-hmm and I
have to I have to believe that if it if
it will it won't be within the first
three four years looking at like the
growth of the corridor channels looking
at the growth of other channel like
minimalist channels that I follow like
it there's years of patients that have
to go into just like you start with
putting your idea out there and you
slowly have to change your raw idea to
something that's just a little bit more
refined for people to digest
consistently yeah got to make the
compromise with yourself you know first
what people want to watch versus what
you want to do yeah it seems like you
you started doing what smaller or
shorter episodes to try to make it more
digestible no so we we play for about
three hours a game and we take a break
in the middle and we just release two
parts of that okay so we just released
one on Tuesday one on Thursday yeah
sit down record one so you got two
uploads I tried releasing them even
shorter and for the style that the show
this specific game goes you kind of just
want to sit there and digest it like a
podcast sure mm-hmm where if it's
something that's more like heavy edited
more cinematic something like
node D&D shows you can cut that in farm
smaller bites yeah yeah it's almost like
if you keep it raw you just need to keep
everything in you know like ya can't
start being cheesy yeah so see Mike
releasing the hurts and the end of our
time here together for this podcast I
want to say so far like your yeah your
your story of like the you know what
kind of what happened from leaving
corridor to trying to make it work to
the stress in the pack to you know
working with black rifle like that was
fascinating like I was completely
engrossed like listening I was
transported to another world I might be
come out to be a dungeon master after
all yeah that was really cool and and
you know I really appreciate you sharing
that and like sharing your
vulnerabilities as well as your
successes should I think is something
you've always been that from you guys at
corridor like it's when we said when I
started shooting BTS for you guys it was
just like capture what they're doing but
make it better and then the vlog was
where my brain started like freaking out
and cracking and breaking how do I make
this work it doesn't make sense and it's
like oh it's you you have to open up you
just have to let the thing happen and
you have to film it and then you have to
think about it while it's happening
while not thinking about while it's
happening it's so surreal and it just
goes into like like and what I like to
do which is make content whether it gets
the numbers or not what what I like to
do is make something that people can
just enjoy
and to do that you have to think of
those audience members and think what
they would think while you're making it
and you can't be you can't judge it you
you can't like be selfish about it and I
think during like that dark mental
transition of me leaving corridor that
was infesting my relationship with the
content and I could see often it would
affect how I communicate with you guys
and I didn't want that either
and I knew that was not a problem in the
sense of like I'm gonna get fired but
it's like it's a problem because it's
shouldn't be that's not okay it's not
morally or ethically okay like I'm I'm
trying to make I have to make something
that makes people feel better I have I
can't start from a dark place mm-hmm and
I'm just constantly trying to be that
like in 60 years look back was I able to
be better to make better yeah those are
words of wisdom man those are good
philosophies to live by and things to
pursue it's hard to do it but I think
you know in the moment it could be a big
struggle when you set out to do your own
thing you try to figure out how to make
it work but I mean I'm saying this a bit
from a position of privilege and that
you know corridor has been successful
but even if it wasn't and you know even
those times were it wasn't you know
looking back from the day it's still
going on doing your own thing is one of
those things like you look back at it
and something that you pre pretty much
never regret you know it's like they do
that study like you know old people and
asked what do they what do they value
more in their life their experiences or
the like that like or what they value
spending their money more on you know
expensive items or expensive experiences
traveling dancers always experiences you
know items items just don't me have the
same thing as you know emotions and
memories and things that make you grow
and so you know when you set out to do
your own thing like even if it is a
struggle and even a bit as hard and the
money isn't always there I think it's
one of those things that like you know
people survive you make your way through
it and you look back at years down the
line you know makes you a better person
when you've pursued things like that you
know it's being able to decide to do
something of your own volition is such a
valuable thing to be able to do and so
still a few people still do that like
you know when you're talking about when
you're working at Imperium games and you
want to go do Phil Mordor and they're
like well you won't have a job when you
come back you're like that's cool see ya
like if more people were willing to do
that he would be in a world where people
would be taken advantage of as much
because you have to have that sense of
righteousness for yourself and doing
right by yourself first and being your
own person yeah having the ability to
empathize with who you work with I think
like one of the one of the benefits of
like while working on fables and working
with a client whether it's black rifle
or someone else is if you're trying to
make a youtube channel it's like I know
what you're going through like I know
the thoughts are going through your head
I know the stress that's going through
your head I know what numbers you're
looking at so like level with me talk
with me and let's collaborate as people
to make something that your audience
your your community wants to see yeah
yes also I think my favorite I think
it's season three of the vlogs where
Nick and I hit a stride where Nick would
make videos mostly with Jake where it's
just like the antic
crazy video with a cinematic storyline
and then I would just focus on this like
weird personal thing that's happening
the audience rigging crazy gentle crazy
video to be stories for years there yeah
yeah
so obviously it goes without saying that
anybody listening to this podcast should
go check out you know fables obviously
there'll be links on the screen and in
the description a lot of kind of stuff
but you know I think people should go
check out your patreon as well because
when you have a small dedicated audience
it you gotta have more than just add
revenue to make it happen and you can
totally make it happen with a small
audience but it requires that audience
to be willing to support you I mean
something we've talked about on this
podcast before as you know we launched
our corridor site as well
congrat by the way thank you I mean it's
still in beta so you know I would say
that congrats for when it's like
officially launched when leaving quarter
I was also like kind of thinking about
something similar because I was looking
at colleges humours dropout mm-hmm I was
like oh so like I need patreon to make
this thing even think about happening
yeah it's like you can't rely on the
views you can't rely on the ad revenue
my goods especially if you're trying to
start something yeah yeah you shouldn't
start something from that perspective
you know it's not gonna turn out well
yeah so when I started I owned none of
the equipment that I use borrowing now I
still only own 75% of it as better than
0% yeah
it's also it's really easy to forget
like you know when you're you're on
YouTube you're looking at like the big
names and like 5 million views for video
like man that's a lot of views I'm only
getting like a couple thousand it's like
a thousand people is a lot of people
yeah like specially there I'm in a room
with a thousand people when you have
it's very small amount of times and
they're never having their attention
pointed at one thing all right yeah
being on a stage in front of a thousand
people and commanding their attention
for an hour
is crazy but yet people are like it
doesn't it doesn't register like that
when you like you do a podcast in 1,000
people listen to it or you do like a
live game and a thousand people watch it
it's like it's not a million it's like
that's a thousand people you're on stage
in front of a thousand people like
that's a lot that was nervous when I
move because of all the hype of me
moving the fables mm-hmm the first like
I don't know five videos like 10,000
20,000 50,000 views I'm like this is
gonna go away so fast
see how broke I really am and couch but
now it's settled
roughly I get a thousand roughly a
thousand views per video I upload a
thousand eyeballs that like the thing I
create that so humbling right and then
after a couple months of it I learn then
like the math of it and I changed my my
patreon tiers and so each tier says how
many views you would actually support
nice start yeah well seem like this is
great thank you for joining us on this
podcast I want to do another one at some
point here yeah but it's really nice to
catch enough here and like hearing your
stories and your tales your fables yeah
this is super cool is there anything
else you'd want to say to people or I
guess ask them to check out or anything
like that I mean I just be humble if
people check out fables I know it's not
I know it's not node D and E I'm sorry I
can't afford the minis but like I just
be humble if you check that out I'm not
going to ask people to sign up for
patreon or join the channel not right
now that's I don't feel like that's a
good idea but I would want to yeah I
think knowing the
demographic of the corridor fanbase I
have like time short you I started a
corridor in my mid-20s I'm 30 just
turned 30
hey my birthday is the same day as
corridors it like if you want to make
something go do it like Sam you just
proved to any filmmaker out there they
have no excuse
like I know it's like talking about like
[ __ ] on your phone like I'm I'm always
like uh it doesn't look right unless you
know you get the close-up or something
like that but like if you want to make
something you want to put your idea out
there do it if if you don't if you don't
feel good about something that you're
doing like do the work to figure out how
to stop doing that so you can put the
energy into something that you need to
put energy into and if you have to like
also love everyone you work with love
like don't burn bridges mm-hmm like
that's not gonna turn out great when
you're 60 yeah I mean I think you
demonstrated just how small the video
world is I mean the world in general is
small like the fact that you're at shot
show and the other two guys like
Carmichael you know or the fact that
Richard Ryan calls you up you know it's
like it's not a big world out there
no yeah like it's it's it's so
mind-blowing that our parents were so
right that they're like you don't know
anything you knew you know a lot when
you're young you do know a lot because
you have your own experiences your own
paths but you don't you don't have the
perspective that you get by just
starting over yeah
it gives you empathy I think it's hard
to have empathy when you aren't
experienced yeah super deep alright I
think that's a perfect like walked off
into the sunset
[Laughter]
fun fact most of the subscribe screams
that I ever put in word was actually
Nick it was short enough more than
people got so frustrated thing we're
trying to give them like supplemental
advertising they're just seeking a
little like subscribe words like trying
to trick people in subscribing and
hypnotize us like that's a joke guys I
miss so many things that I used to
create with you guys but one of the
things that I do like cry laughing over
is Mario Kart and just before we end
it's so surreal
like being able to look I mean for all
of us right being able to look back at
the last five years and literally about
vlog that catalogs almost everything of
your day to day right I mean even though
it's kind of like curated and you know
presented it's very like I'll look back
at vlogs that I haven't seen for years
man and I'll just it feels like it was
just yesterday but at the same time it's
super tricky because things even though
they're the same they're very different
you know yeah it gives a really start
only three years ago but it's been five
yeah those videos are my memories like
when I watch those I'm like yeah but at
the same time you can like remember like
what went into making each one you know
like it's just it's a vault then that's
a vault and I sometimes like when I'm
looking for b-roll for like
and video I'll just go down you know
you'll get stuck in the recommended
stuff yeah
thanks sorry for listening and for
checking out the podcast see Mike it was
a pleasure having you on
you are as well-spoken as I've always
remembered you to be cool and I guess
you know we already said it but go check
out Carmichael's channel but I will tell
you to go support him on patreon if only
if only if you're into a stuff I think
that's important to say like you're a
toreador yes you can afford if you can't
afford it don't feel bad watch the
videos then yeah but yeah it was it's
been an absolute pleasure thank you
everybody for listening and yeah we'll
see everyone in the next quarter cast so
long everybody